this week we've got surprise tiger ass
man and Banzai test test
sorry people that-that grassman and
theft no he's like in Spanish the way
Mexican people if they speak Spanish
first they have a hard time doing the th
like my mom she can't say thrifty she
says drifty so how do you say that
so this it's not just deep th it's not
just yet oh it depends on like like
thrifty first about BAE how do you say
hey hey I'm gay is easy there's like so
I picture like de why yeah hey why don't
you picture like death I just don't say
that word often if I practice I don't
know if I'll get it next time
guys next time yeah sometimes my 3 comes
out my 3 right 3 and furry we're like
the hardening but I think that's dope
because you [ __ ] speak multiple
languages that's think wow pans your
quadrant alright so for our first story
this person in Houston went into an
abandoned home because they're trying to
find somewhere to get high and I know
this one sorry yeah I read this they
came face to face with an overweight
tiger no well we're document human I
didn't know that obviously the tiger in
India would be more normal it wouldn't
have been over wasting seeds a brisket
so sad
oh no it's sad imagine walking in and I
mean thank God for this good citizen for
this crackhead I need to find a place to
that's money or when it's a crack give
me the facts okay I want to imagine a
crackhead that just broke into an
abandoned house and I'm imagining like
graffiti all over a [ __ ] flipped up
mattress all [ __ ] up and then they're
about to hit that crack and then the
tiger comes out and they're like am i
hallucinating
well you say the facts
what kind of stoner those just creeping
around in abandoned houses I feel like
it's more of a crack probably like a
younger person like trying to find a
place to smoke weed all right cuz weed
is still hella legal in Texas it is you
think you wouldn't just like if you
smoked a lot of pot you're not like
creeping through abandoned houses I feel
like well I guess it's very young and
you don't have those things yeah we used
to go behind like houses when we were
younger yeah yeah he's got smoking out
live that life man I was I was on time I
was in school all right we got it you're
white I'm not smoking into an art school
I did I'm surprised he didn't smoke weed
then well all my teachers were high I
wasn't but yes Lilly Regina smokes of
weed and then they found this tiger but
then they called authorities but then
the authorities were like yeah held on
are you sure you're not hallucinating
like for sure you see a tiger in front
of you they're like yes there's a tiger
here was he a Mike Tyson's house he
should have been like full i'ma text you
right now what's your number inside this
cage that was too small that is he was
in a cage yeah it was in a cage so
someone was keeping him there so was
keeping him there so apparently it is
legal to have to own a tiger if you have
a big game license yeah but it's illegal
to have it in Houston oh good you got to
be like outside the city or something
and you gotta live it in like condition
we don't know but we just know that this
tiger was being well fed obviously
boys easy fat they report as an
overweight tiger that's bad shaming I'm
sure he's happy
it looks really good where's the buzz at
body-positive Tigers living like in a
[ __ ] box your whole life how many
years was it there wait he was in that
cage the whole time that's how they
found the tiger in the cage
they're saying that
so it's a female tiger weighing
approximately a thousand pounds oh yeah
they were lucky enough to find a local
Texas Animal Sanctuary hold that's cool
I wonder if I could pet the tiger
because I'm allergic to cats like I'm
not even lying I hate animal cruelty
hell yeah how do you even do that though
like what's the process of getting a
[ __ ] tiger to Texas like a private
airplane dude they get drugs from here
to there like nothing you think they can
get animals yeah a thousand pound Tigers
different than probably a baby and then
it grew yeah what you just saw today in
a United fight in your little carry-on
in your injury I don't think it's
illegal did you hear how Mike Tyson got
his tiger on the podcast door oh no no
no no so he was in jail and then his car
dealer comes and visit something goes
hey were you gonna do it always card on
one of these cars yours if not I'm
trying to play horses oh you got horses
and then you is that yeah I got more
horses I got Tigers I got camels were
Rosie Vegas he was in jail but he
ordered Tigers do you don't know the
black market you can get anything dude
you can get human horn I'm not saying he
got home with tiger cubs waiting for him
so I don't think it's illegal though no
I know yeah because you can get an
exotic pet license and all that in some
areas you can get Tigers yeah yeah no
I'm not so I'm not saying how Mike Tyson
gotta I'm saying how the guy got it to
get it to Mike Tyson Oh
like that's got to be illegal money all
you have to do is drug the animal and
then you touch it I know but like the
actual process just seems weird like you
just fly out to India and now you're
just [ __ ] roaming around fight a
tiger you just stab it with morphine
throw it and I'll carry on luggage
basically yeah that's exactly it
I think so can you imagine doing that
it's not clueless they imagine doing
that I'm not but we don't do that we
don't do that okay I feel like if I
wanted a tiger probably get one in like
a week or two yeah so I'll find my
friend that's into fish tanks that
already has illegal fits what I mean
though you're homie yeah I'll ask that
guy and that guy will probably know
someone that can get like an illegal
iguana and that cop I know how to get a
monkey and a tiger whatever I'm talking
about the guy that gets it though not a
purchase he's talking about how its
smuggled yeah and then all smuggling
seems they don't ask that guy how he did
he applied some make him in the
container from time Anderson for example
something way smaller scale like a puppy
mill right yeah like how do you make
that happen in the u.s. because they're
legal it's not legal I think a puppy
mills are legal technically it's a
buttermilk yeah it's not legal well
that's the illegals it's fun it's when
they breathe does you just breathe dog I
think puppy was a term for a shitty
shitty breeder though oh it is so it's a
dog breeder but they just live in really
shitty conditions and all they do is
they keep this female dog pregnant so
she can't walk she can't move anywhere
she's just throwing cages and they
constantly just make her [ __ ] breathe
it's so sad yeah but that the
application are like the smuggling
parter that's simple to me oh you get a
dog you get a mail you get a fiower you
do it right here getting a goddamn
thousand-pound tiger from India to huge
that way of cause it wasn't a little
when I got yeah it's probably even that
seems weird though it is weird but you
just take people off and there's
probably like tigers that mate in the US
that's why they condemn makes more yeah
there's probably a vice documentary I
could watch no explain highly doubt that
they're full-grown adults in the wild
and then they're taking it yeah they're
domesticated so then there's breeders
already within the US a lot of these
sanctuaries I want to see like 95% of
the Tigers that they have are because
yeah yeah yeah people got them as cubs
yeah yeah and now they can cuz if they
were what in the wild already you can
just release them into wall and they can
they can I know who to ask for Eddie
Cohn
all right right wait do you guys follow
this count it's called black Jaguar
white tiger I love it - he's in Mexico
he has a tiger sanctuary that looks a
little scary though like the way he does
it though they're so friendly with him
I'm not doing that well I think he's
just like that's his life like he has no
family like that he devoted his life to
that and he says that in his captions I
think most items in Spanish but he says
like like I'm only able to get with
these like Tigers til they're like this
age once they get this way or that like
he only like pets um through like the
yeah fans you know yeah cuz I'm sure
these scratches yeah but that's what he
loves
moving on to the next story oh yeah this
one's funny so this takes place in
Canada this man
David Guzman was denied a request to
have a vanity plate of his last name Wow
oh he decided to create his own plates
because his name is use us man maybe nah
so it's pronounced Osman right it's
spelled ass man that's actual last name
yeah it's an actual name wait yo tits or
ass dude you know Oh smile yeah no way I
would always I was just reading ass man
I wish he was a probe of a sports player
I get that Jersey like remember friend
Jason told this I forgot what he was
doing what he had to call people Chen oh
yeah and then he like was like hey
mister [ __ ] and then the guys like
ball it's pronounced shift fed well in
spelling like [ __ ] fed if you think
about it yeah yeah so great great
grandfather came from Jessica Oh Germany
so it's derived from the saxon word ash
or spear and so they're saying that ass
men's are descended from ancient warrior
they are but in today's words their
friend yeah why would you just change it
why would you change he's really proud
of his last name I don't know my family
changed a lesson I'm not changing my
last name we do we change me you could
change the spelling to reflect it I've
got into fights I go a a SH man oh yeah
yeah like all rage whatever the Saxon
root is yeah well I mean he can make it
more authentic I just think he thinks
it's funny he likes I think he's like
[ __ ] yeah I'm DS man you know he doesn't
want to change it I knew it when I
worked at the bank
we had a customer that would come in
like regularly and his last name was
Loveland
Mike that's time that's cute he didn't
look very lovely but you want to come to
lovely I know I was like dude how many
times you use to pick up on chicks he's
like all that it was a corpsman on my
old unit corpsman or like the guys in
the Navy that kind of take care of us
like medically and he was Native
American and
his last name was lightning hammer
that's it horn pornstar for sure
so they're saying that in Canada there
are 23 s men's living there that's way
more ass man in America
yeah so there was this one guy named
dick ass man oh no gasps like his first
name is Richard I would change my name
back gotta go gotta go bye Richard no
key
he loved his name so he used it to
advertise his gas station dick ass man -
gasps manee uh guess in Saskatchewan -
because David's also from Saskatchewan
he looks like a thumb with hair can't
imagine how that guy coming up on the
earth man that's disgusting
oh I don't know if I put over a German
spirit peoples he doesn't look like a
German spear person at all
why are you was a little warrior why is
he so proud of his last name he's
claiming name that full of eight drinks
big gulps all day so it's probably the
only thing he has going for him his last
thing man Oh piss and watch this I feel
bad now are you a ass man sorry you mr.
ass man
smart smart fry I've been struggling
this whole episode with my sous man is
it oh oh s ma an oh you smell the way
they spilled it in this article is OSM
en mousse men Oh
OSS Osman I thought it was Spanish you
know like I Guzman Guzman yeah thought I
was like that I think there's some like
a Turkish sounding names or confident
ass man booze man there's a USC fighters
last names who's smart nickname for us
men I think that's a dope name though I
like it I wouldn't try to [ __ ] up that
he didn't get to keep it
I know no he's license plate that looks
just like the license plate woods you
should've gone like he should have gone
a to two men but they would allowed it
but imagine like you're driving on the
freeway and then you see that the back
of his truck and then you pull up next
to him and you're like girl yes man like
I would not be in personally that you'd
be kind of crosstalk gee like yo you
lookin at my ass
Oh like you pull up their legs you're a
pervert yeah yeah it is I would
and I was like too big no that's yadus
down so what if it was like the rock and
then you pull up and it's like oh I'd be
like okay you like I asked cuz I got one
haha alright for a last story these
Japanese bonsai owners are urging the
thieves because they stole a 400 year
old tree worth 127 it's no joke that
shit's really expensive
thousand that's a lot of money yeah
there's some that go like half a million
that's a hundred thousand yeah plants
yeah they're saying that no there's my
old they are big depends on how old a I
don't know I'm just guessing I [ __ ] up
my bonsai tree that should maybe like
are they're hard to take care of Wow and
there would be but I forgot to water it
that's when they stole 400 years old
yeah 400 years old do they stay that
size yeah well you gotta trim it but but
yeah but it doesn't go like good Roble
it takes a lot of patience and like you
really have to nurture these trees so
the this couple here from Japan they
were saying that these thieves stole
bonsai trees totally like collectively
it was worth at least 165 thousand
dollars yeah and so they're just so
distraught they're they're trying to get
the word out there to the thieves like
hey please make sure you're watering
these be there like babies yeah because
they might [ __ ] it up yeah they're there
tree babies they're saying that this 400
year old tree to them it's like their
child is this an here ours in Japan do
they have children does it say I don't
know that's [ __ ] up and I just want
taking your dog I feel like that's your
problem now this fall shits everywhere
bites you know haha well they're saying
that there's like a family practice that
digs deep back all the way to 1603 oh so
it's like a family yeah - it probably
stayed in their family for like hundreds
of yeah the best I'd imagine like your
great-great-great great-great grandpa
like touch this and you're like oh my
gosh there's no here that's pretty cool
cuz like how far back does any year
generational stuff go I think I have
like something that my grandma and
that's it yeah I think my grandma - I
think all I know is my grandparents I
have a picture of my great-grandpa is it
kind of like half a 2
because it's old no it's so what they
did is they found like an old picture of
them and there's this theme that you can
do or you take the picture and they
somehow imprint it on a piece of stone
so I like it's supposed to be like
indestructible or whatever you know so
we have that stone so I think I have a
great great grandparent or something but
it's like it's like a picture but it's
like kind of drawn you know I mean you
kind of like those Disneyland things
they make kind of they're like they'll
do it like a board photos yeah yeah like
it looks it looks identical but I've
been pretty damn sure it's called like a
homeboy back here kinda oh it's old
condo I just and so but it is drawing
like why not like oh not detective a
sketchy now a piston yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's about that's um oh that's
not 400 years old wait so then they get
they got robbers in their house and they
just took everything when they came
specifically for the for the trees um no
they didn't take everything like they
mute they're saying that these are
professionals because they picked out
the most valuable Oh probably a nursery
or something yeah yeah cuz it's a family
business right
oh damn rival nursery maybe it was
someone on the family they probably just
picked the ones that are behind the
counter I know they're saying that
they're just so sad and they've just
hope that they're being taken care it's
super easy to steal in Japan
really why yeah like no one even lock
their door like when we first went there
we were saying in an Airbnb and then I
forgot who had the address or whatever
so we're following that one person and
like oh this is our house so I'm gonna
take off our shoes we call upstairs and
there's someone like on the couch just
watching TV sleeping and then we're like
okay wait this in the house okay so we
got out and the person didn't even know
there were 20 people inside that home
and they don't even know yeah they
didn't even know they could have been
sleeping there or was it a lot yeah it
wasn't there's no crime ah yeah thieving
is just the lowest of the low like what
just don't think you're gonna do it yeah
cuz be even gangsters rather like robbed
you to your face than to steal like
stealing is like low low [ __ ] that's why
I like they have a bunch of bikes there
and nothing's like locked so if you lock
your bike for example do they look at
you weird
probably cuz I know because I've seen no
there's no locks on bikes and most of
the thieving comes from like foreigners
or some Pig pop
did this study where they not even I
study but then in the experiment work in
Japan someone would drop their wallet
right and then just walk away and I
think like a hundred percent of like
that happening like a hundred percent of
the people picked it up and they ran
after the person that dropped you forgot
a camera one of the stores and they ran
like a couple blocks of try to get them
wow that is so cool yeah depends and
there are there are poor people there
but they just don't I don't know it's
different you know I was watching this
documentary - on immigrants in Japan and
there was there was actually a Mexican
guy and and I forgot why he was in Japan
but he was saying how like he he lost
his wallet at the train station and then
somehow they got ahold of them and then
and then when he got there he got his
wallet with the money and he was just so
surprised oh yeah I'm excellent yeah so
then so he decided to play it forward
and one day he found a phone and then so
he found the phone and he tried to
figure out whose phone it was and then
so he's like because of living there it
changed how he started to approach like
things like even walking around the
streets there was not a single like
piece of trash on that
really or at all in any of the streets
no trash at all no gum on the sidewalk
but this time I like I just I wanted to
keep even the gum wrapper and I felt
dirty in there I felt like I was a trash
in Japan I blinked and I caught it
before you how do you duplicate that
around the world though hundreds of you
just got put Japanese people everywhere
what has happened like Manhattan we've
had a lot of crime I think in like the
90s and then they just decided to add
more lights and clean the streets and
yeah it's like that one of this
literally I think the safest city in
America like Manhattan Island you know
because they have hella lights there are
cops and tons of pee it's like a
multi-front battle I feel like people
are trying to put you just one thing you
gotta do like three or four things yeah
they did they were in an environmental
way yeah
[Music]
[Music]